all right Thank You Marci
so hello Cascadia Jas welcome to this
talk how many people are feeling drowsy
after lunch shine some light on these
people right here we want to make sure
that I asked a few questions during my
talk wake people up alright so for the
next half an hour or so I'm going to
pretend to know a few things about
JavaScript but like Marcy said I do
security research so hopefully you'll go
along with the facade and not call me
out if I say something wrong but but I
spend my time looking at malware and I
thought I could share some of the
JavaScript malware they've been seeing
lately on the Internet in the wild so
this talk is called Raiders or the
JavaScript based malware all right so
the two important threats that I wanted
to discuss is an example of a ransomware
that is written entirely in JavaScript
which is which is something we didn't
even know could happen as security
researchers because we always see
ransomware written in C or C++ one of
those languages right but this
ransomware is written entirely in
JavaScript the second thing the second
important thing we want to discuss was
crypto jacking and crypto jacking is
proliferating on the Internet and what
we want to discuss a little bit about
that as well so let's go ahead and get
started a little bit about me a little
bit about a group I work as part of the
security research group at Michigan
State University before I was a PhD
candidate there before I started my PhD
there I used to do independent
penetration testing so you know finding
flaws security weaknesses for clients
and then getting them a report at the
end of it so that they can fix the
security holes so I am an active speaker
or security conferences this is the
first time I'm speaking at a conference
which is not a security conference so
this is pretty exciting for me and a
little nerve-wracking but but so this
slide kind of introduces some of the
threats some of the new stories that
I've seen over the past week so these
are pretty recent so Ransome is not a
ransomware it's not going anywhere
you know financially motivated cyber
criminals love to use rants
we're encrypted jackin attacks to make
the money and it's not going anywhere
because because it keeps making them
money so why would they
you know discard of this amazing method
they have to to make money and and
what's new is we is is the JavaScript
based ransomware that we've just seen so
the the elements of a ransomware before
I go ahead and jump into the JavaScript
based ransomware called Raa ransomware
and focus on the code and the JavaScript
details of the JavaScript involved there
I want to discuss the basic elements of
a ransomware
so it starts with an initial entry right
so just like any other infection you
want to gain an entry into the host so
there's a bunch of ways to do that I'm
sure all of you are familiar with social
engineering attacks you know so you know
traditional phishing emails they have a
document attached if you if you get an
unsuspecting you know user to download
and double click it then it executes the
malicious functionality on their system
right and then there are other ways that
we've seen recently which they're
they're using which is exporting known
vulnerabilities if you're not updating
your PC's regularly and they also love
to exploit weakly secured RDP sessions
or Isis s sessions if you if you haven't
got got a strong password on there and
and that sort of thing so the next thing
they need to do is get an encryption
secret which means that all right they
need to have a unique key per victim if
for every infection they need to have a
unique key why because you're a part of
their big ransomware campaign and if
they have the same key for every victim
then vicked once a victim pays let's say
300 dollars for for the ransom and gets
the key back then that key can be shared
with the rest of the users and that
neutralizes the entire ransomware
campaign so it's important for them to
get this unique encryption secret per
victim right and then and then they go
ahead and start with file encryption so
they search for specific file types they
don't want to encrypt dll's
that doesn't do them any good because
you can just restore that but what you
cannot restore which is your personal
data so if you don't have a backup right
so they are looking to encrypt docx
xlsx and so that's that sort of thing so
you know they they like to
finally they like to demand ransom which
is usually around $300 in
cryptocurrencies so with the
understanding of the general elements of
ransomware let's take a look at our a
ransomware so this is the first
ransomware like I like I've said that's
written entirely in JavaScript and it
uses the default windows script host no
I did not know that by default Windows
has the windows script host which is a
scripting engine that executes
JavaScript on Windows so if a user so
what they do is they send a phishing
email to a user and the attachment is
something likes something underscore doc
underscored dot je s now the users users
are generally trained to think that it's
normally exe s or executable files that
are malicious so they would they're more
likely to download a CSV file thinking
that it's benign right so they'll
download it and then double-clicking it
means that windows script host will
execute it all right so now they have
execution capability on host then they
use a bunch of JavaScript obfuscation
tactics because in case of C and C++ the
code isn't always visible you have to
the source code is invisible to us as
malware analysts but in case of
JavaScript the source code is right
there so for that reason they want to
make it hard for us to understand what's
going on and for that reason they use a
lot of obfuscation tactics which
basically means they break anything
you've learned about coding standards
and good coding practices they do the
opposite of that so it makes it
difficult to read this one likes to add
insult to injury this is not a primary
functionality of a ransomware but this
one likes to also drop a Trojan in the
background that spies on you and steals
your information so you know no ethics
in the cyber criminal you know in the
cyber criminal world anymore like what's
the world coming to
so these are these are what we call
indicators of compromise which means
these are symptoms of an infection in
the security industry we like to you
know use these as a metric towards okay
do you have this specific and in you
know infection so a primary way to do it
is to look at hashes in this particular
J's file these are the sha
and md5 hashes that are you know that
indicated that okay you're hit with this
particular ransomware then you can look
at dropped files so once it once it
executes on a system you can see the
files it drops in this particular case
it drops st dot exe which is that pony
trojan that steals your information so
that's another indicator and then
network activity it makes a dns request
to start wave now calm which is its
command and control server i'll be
discussing that in a little bit but
that's where it goes to for commands so
once you execute this what i'm going to
do is i'm going to show you the system
impact and then I'll discuss the
JavaScript code that leads to that
system impact so this is the process
graph once you execute it W script exe
is the window scripting host that I was
talking about and that basically creates
two processes WordPad exe and st dot exe
SC dot exe is the Tony the pony Trojan
that I was talking about and warpath dot
exe just puts a diversion screen in
front of your face which distracts you
while it's executing malicious
functionality in the background so this
is the example this is that divergence
screen that I was talking about it's in
Russian you know a big surprise there
it's so this is an error code they are
basically telling users that you know
this particular version of Microsoft
Word or whatever cannot open this
document for this reason so while you're
busy dealing with that and while you're
trying to click close it jumps around so
when you try to get to the close button
it jumps around so while you're trying
to figure out how can I close this
particular window it execute malicious
functionality in the background so and
it doesn't need a lot of time to do that
a few seconds is enough a network
activity in the meanwhile you know in
the in the meantime network activity
something like this it makes several
requests to DNS requests to start wave
now calm which is its command and
control server and it's the potential
source of the unique encryption key that
I was talking about when I was talking
about the primary elements of ransomware
so that's where it acquires this unique
encryption key from right but the CNC
server
in case of many of these infections the
malicious domains get
taken down obviously once they're
recognized so this particular CNC server
has been taken down now so we can't
really study what response it gets back
to from the server anymore but if you
look at the code so two of the things
that I didn't show was it then encrypts
the files so if it let's say if it found
your docx or your xlsx it will then
replace that with an encrypted version
and then what it will do next is you
know have a ransom note in every folder
of your computer so you know because
having a ransom note on one computer
isn't enough so it's on one folder isn't
enough so it just goes ahead and in
every folder you have you've got on your
computer it will put a ransom note up
there so so crypto j/s library is a big
part of this ransomware we've seen that
ransomware developers are at coding
so well so what they do is they engage
in a lot of cargo called programming
they steal code from each other they
copy paste code from let's say wiki CPP
and things like that so they already
can't get many things right so why would
they want to implement crypto
functionality from scratch because
there's a lot of room for error there so
what they do is they use some kind of
cryptographic library in this particular
case they use the crypto JS library so
the first 800 lines of this ransomware
contains the crypto J's code has just
copy paste in so that's where it gets
its crypto functionality from now the
next part is the the diversion message
so the the message that I showed you on
the screen on WordPad Exe in Russian
that comes from here so if you look at
this part right here by the way also
notice the code obfuscation here the
function names and the variable names
there they're very difficult to read
they're just a bunch of random
characters so that makes it hard for you
to follow along with their code so in
this particular function this variable
holds a long string which is you know
then basics before decoded and then it
drops this particular you know decoded
string in my documents then creates this
doc underscore attached underscore a
random story
and and then puts it in front of your
face by opening WordPad exe and pasting
this on there so that's what that
diversion screen was all right so then
we talked about decrypting the pony
Trojan because like I said st dot exe is
pertains to the pony trojan that spies
on your information right so this
function is responsible for creating
that and this is pretty impressive
because they use JavaScript to create a
binary executable file by and by
encoding and encrypting the whole binary
in the in string format in there so it's
hard coded in there so what it does is
this is the this is a very long string
by the way it's truncated over here but
it's a very long string which contains
the entire code for Pony Trojan and then
and then it decrypt it by using the AES
encryption algorithm or decryption
algorithm and then and then the the key
for that is also encoded as part of the
ransomware and then it uses that eval
command to basically get to this point
so that eval evaluates to over here and
so this is what it evaluates to and this
is what drops the Pony Trojan where it
goes in the my documents' creates that
file SP dot exe which is the Trojan and
care set 437 pertains to well it lets it
figure out how to handle this executable
binary data in string formats so that's
what that pertains to you'll see that
throughout this ransomware is code and
then you see write text safety file
close that file
so obviously it's creating that file now
on in the My Documents folder and then
finally it runs the file so now the
trojan is executing on your computer
next thing it needs to do is now it
needs to actually perform its ransomware
functionality which is to encrypt drives
so to do that what it does is it uses
the basic object available as part of
the windows script host to create to go
through the drives and enumerate the
drives dry letters and then access
different files and folders and you know
source through the files and their
extensions to know which files to
encrypt and so on
so you'll see things like this else
continue and then there's this is the
equivalent of a go-to statement you know
and this makes this code further
complicated to understand because this
makes it a spaghetti code if they have a
bunch of random go-to jumps at random
spots it makes this hard to follow along
the the execution flow of their of their
bite of their code so further off the
station tactics that these the ransom
note comes from here and and then this
pertains to encrypting the users files
which which means that this particular
function right here calls this function
in a loop once for every file that it
wants to encrypt so this particular
function that is called in the loop
within the other function will be
encrypting each and every file going
through deriving functionality from the
crypto jeaious library that's that I
showed you in the beginning and you know
they use the AES encryption algorithm to
do this so a quick summary you know it
obviously encrypts files on the user's
computer on the user's computer but it
also deletes VSS files what I didn't
show you for the sake of brevity is it
also performs certain other tasks like
deleting VSS files these are volumes
shadow copies that are maintained on
windows so you know you can use Windows
Restore to restore to an earlier point
so if you do that obviously ransomware
has lost its leverage on you so what
what they like to do is make sure they
eliminate any backups in any form so
because of that they want to get rid of
those VSS volume shadow copies so it
likes to do that as well like I said it
drops
you know the the Trojan horse which is
not which is not really something every
ransomware does but this one does so so
that's unique to this ransomware and and
the Trojan is dropped in My Documents
folder so you know in in summary it was
very interesting for us as
to see that there's a ransomware now
written entirely in JavaScript I mean
who knew that JavaScript is a full-blown
programming language you know so that so
the next threat is scripted right Jackie
and I want to quickly touch upon this as
well because this is the second biggest
thing we're seeing in 2018 so ransomware
has been you know continuing since 2005
2006 is when it took off and now it's
steadily growing right but cryptid
jacking took off after following the
rise in the valuation of
cryptocurrencies so around the end of
2017 Bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies
took off and and so of course it took
other cryptocurrencies like maneras
valuation up with it and then we are
introduced to web crypto jacking and and
it's the unauthorized use of processing
power and electricity to mine
cryptocurrencies so if you go on a
website I'll show you the web examples
of this because that is more relevant to
JavaScript and so so the web-based
examples of this would be something like
this where you'll go on a website and if
you look through the source code you'll
see a little script being called from
coin Hyper's of particular is a popular
source for these scripts where they'll
import the script from coin hive and it
will initiate a coin hive instance in
the browser and that is the that that
number that unique string you see in the
box is the ID of the attacker and that
is where you know it credits all the all
the money so you mind you're basically
mining for someone else while you're
visiting this web page so you can see
how it can get lucrative if you have
thousands and thousands of visitors
visiting on your website and say staying
on that web page for a long amount of
time so how do you do that how do you do
that
you you just you just give that you just
tell them that there's like HD porn free
HD porn on this on this link and people
will click it's amazing so you know
so here we go
so you know scripts as seen on the
crypto jackin websites more examples of
that this one is an example with crypto
loot doing the same thing so it's not
just coin hive it's sometimes also
crypto loot and there's other sources as
well so what are the impact on on system
resources alright we did a little
experiment just to see how much what
they do and this was when this threat
was very new so just the beginning of
2018 so you know that's the that's the
before and after shot and you know
before you see that the course you know
that this the computer is at normal
usage and then you visit one website you
know one webpage with with this crypto
jacking script enabled in the background
and you see that all four cores are not
being used 200 percent of their capacity
and the CPU temperature rises and and if
you look at the top process is the web
content that's draining ninety seven
point five percent of your CPU power
right now which is you know kind of
stupid of them because this makes it
really easy to notice but they'll get
cleverer and that's what that's what the
problem is that is they're they're in a
learning phase right now at least as far
as crypto jacking attacks are concerned
so they will figure out that it's better
to mine slower and you know get away
with it for a long duration than to do
something like this where you'll
probably notice it pretty quickly
because your computer slows down as well
you know you're draining electricity and
you know that sort of thing so you know
it this is more obvious then we see
examples like this so in this particular
case if you look at the source code of
the website you won't really see right
away where the cryptid jacking script is
hidden so if you're looking for coin
high or crypto loot or some one of those
other you know miners you won't really
see it right away but there's that eval
function again I I recently read
something about evil isn't evil it's
just misunderstood yeah right you know I
see see it and ransomware seen in crypto
jackin so so this is the this is that
eval function taken from the taken from
the source code and this is what it
evaluates to so again as you can see
it's it's the it's the same old coin
hive script that is
porting and mining on people's computer
and and the problem with this is that
now if you want to help by writing a
crawler or something that crawls the web
looking for different cryptid jacking
websites and let's say that the string
you put in there is look for coin hive
in crypto loot and things like that this
makes it harder for you to get there
because you know now that now it's
hidden behind this eval statements how
would you write that curie you know how
would you how would you make an
automatic analysis towards you know if
if there's you know crypto jacking on
this website or not so that that makes
it a little more complicated so I did a
preliminary analysis basically I was
looking to crawl the internet looking
for what websites are involved encrypted
jacking and that sort of thing it didn't
go very well because there's a lot a lot
of roadblocks but what I was able to do
is identify using my automated analysis
identify 212 websites in Walled
encrypted jacking and what I wanted to
do is resolve these categories resolve
these websites to category see what kind
of categories are involved more likely
to get in Walled encrypted jackin so if
you visit a website and it's crypto
jackin is it a pornographic website or
you know is it a is it already serving
other kinds of malware or what kind of
website is that so for that i used for
40 guard has 40 guard web filter
categorizes websites in several
categories like you know pornography and
you see the examples in that little
chart i'm showing so so what it does is
curies so that little python script on
the right it Curie's the 40 guard server
for a particular websites once I've
determined that this website is cryptid
jacking then I resolve it to a
particular category and then see how
many we can find you know a lot a lot of
them in already are malicious websites a
lot of them are pornography websites and
that sort of thing but there's a lot of
problems like I said during this
analysis because you how do you crawl
the web that's a big task so for that
what I did was I utilized public.www
nerdy data senses they've already got
caches maintained where they because
they already have crawlers that are
crawling the the internet looking for
webpages and they're looking at web
pages and their source codes so if you
just Curie their cache
you don't have to write it on crawler
which was take which would take forever
so okay we can kind of get away with
doing that but how how do we determine
the unauthorized part doing this
automated automated analysis right
because there's legitimate uses of
cryptocurrency mining on a webpage for
example there's an example of a website
where they're asking to donate to
charity by clicking on you know Stark
mining and then staying on that page and
you can then donate money to charity
that way so we obviously don't want to
include that on the cryptid jacking so
how do we determine the unauthorized
part that requires manual analysis to
see if they're seeking permission from
the user somewhere so that makes it more
complicated so then how do we validate
the results some websites are now and
available so you can some websites have
cleaned their source code so an
obfuscation how do we get around code
obfuscation like I showed that eval
statement so if you're just looking for
coin hive or crypto loot scripts or
things like that then you know if
they've got a they've got a clever eval
statement over there then it doesn't
work that way so maybe there's another
better way of doing this that you know
you guys can figure out so you know in
in conclusion there's probably better
ways to discover crypto jacking websites
on the on the Internet this is not
really my area to write you know a lot
of web crawling scripts and you know
determining maybe there's a better way
that you guys can think of and talk to
me about of doing this and you know
maybe we can protect our users better so
you know some people are coming with
coming up with browser based extensions
that automatically block all
cryptocurrency mining and but they don't
always work so there's maybe you know
some room there for improvement and we
have to stay a step ahead of the
attackers because that's what we do in
the security industry is the constant
cat-and-mouse game and so we have to
determine like this windows script using
the windows script host to execute a
JavaScript based malware is something we
did not really see coming so what are
the other possibilities where they can
use you know JavaScript for malicious
purposes because if we can figure that
out ahead of time then we can maybe
think about you know working around that
so and like I said before the cleverer
ransom
we're encrypted jackin attacks or the
future where they won't mind hundred
percent you know 100 percent of your CPU
they'll be more subtle and sometimes
we've seen instances where what they do
is they open up a so when you go to a
particular website and they're cryptic
jackin you they open us a window in the
background and then they make it really
small and they hide it under the under
the taskbar next to the next to the
clock and and so even if you close the
original webpage or used that other
webpage is still open and continuously
mining and you never notice it so until
the next time you shut down your
computer that's mining for them so
they're getting more cleverer by the day
so we want us to stay a step ahead of
them so yeah if you've got any ideas you
know please get in touch and this is
just a quick introduction to you know
two big problems and and I would love to
talk to you more about that so thank you
very much